las vegas is known for having our bright  city lights yes when you can see them  but most of nevada it's very very dark  because a lot of people live in nevada  parts of rural nevada are home to some  of the best places to stargaze in fact  areas like great basin national park and  death valley are now certified by  the international dark sky association  that sounds like a star wars  organization or something doesn't it  astronomy lovers have a new way to enjoy  the stars in state with the park to park  in the dark astro tourism route all  right so it consists of highways us-95  and us-6 the astrotourism route connects  the two parks there's even there are  even itineraries online to give you the  best experience and we're super excited  we've got tickets to the star train up  at ely i'm so jealous